one of my popular talk series is called
worlds of speculative fiction and we've
been renewed for another year partnering
with the Brookfield public library so I
wanted to reach out to all of my viewers
subscribers followers fans of whatever
form to get some suggestions about which
speculative fiction authors they most
wanted me to read and talk about in the
coming series I've already got eight
picked out that I'm going to tell you
about them in just a few minutes but
I've got four slots so if you want to
leave a comment on this video or where
you see it in social media being posted
leave a comment there I'm gonna tally
those up over say the next week or so
and come up with a short list of who is
going to fit into these four slots so
for those of you who don't know about
this series already let me tell you
about it
it's called worlds of speculative
fiction in part because I do focus on
the narrative universe or world
constructed by the author and I also
look at the philosophical themes at
least some of them that could be coming
up in that authors work and in the past
we've done authors ranging from Tolkien
and Martin all the way through to you
know hard science fiction authors like
like Asimov and and you know new wave
science fiction authors like Ursula kala
Queen we've even looked at a bit of
horror with Lovecraft you can actually
scroll down in the video description
you'll see all the people that we've
done already so don't don't put those in
as suggestions because we've already
done them and you can also see the eight
authors who I've picked out for this
coming year let me tell you about them
and then why don't you leave your
suggestions as a comment and I'll
certainly take it under advisement and
if you could also put why you think that
author would be particularly interesting
for this series so keep in mind that
we're looking for authors that actually
do have some sort of coherent narrative
world and
you know some real philosophical themes
there so this coming year 2018 we're
kicking off in January with you know one
of my favorite authors from all time
jorge luis borges
and we're gonna be looking at a number
of his short stories then we're doing
fritz leiber and his fauit in the gray
mauser series then we're doing a few of
Robert Heinlein novels ones that are
oriented towards the worlds of the
future and in April we're going to do L
Sprague de comps complete enchanter
multiverse very fun books there in May
we're doing Andre Norton's witch world
in June we're doing some of Arthur
Clarke's novels those that are focused
on the mysteriousness of the cosmos and
encounters with alien that in July and
August those are slots where I'm looking
for your input as somebody who would
like to see me engaging with with some
classic science fiction fantasy
alternate you know realities and
histories or whatever falls under the
rubric of speculative fiction September
we're picking up with with a series that
I read parts of when I was younger but
didn't read all the way through gene
Wolfe's book of the New Sun October
we're looking at cj Cera's Alliance
Union universe and then we've got two
more slots open in November and December
so pick who you'd like me to talk about
leave that as a comment whether here on
the video or in the social media where
I'm posting it like my Facebook Google+
LinkedIn Twitter and I will certainly
take it under advisement then I'll do a
final poll when I you know reduce the
number down to a manageable amount
because I'm sure we're gonna get a lot
of different suggestions and I'll let
you know about that you again that'll
probably be in my my social media but I
might do another video specifically just
about that with a poll at the end so if
you're going to participate in this let
me thank you in advance for giving me
some useful suggestions again
member I really like not just him
author's names but also why you think
they would be particularly good for this
series so you know before I end this let
me just say that this is one of my
favorite talk series that I've been
doing and I think I could do this for
years to come I'm really enjoying
rereading some of the classics that I
had read as a teenager or you know in my
20s and coming back to them and looking
at them as a philosopher I'm also
enjoying the suggestions that I've
gotten from the people involved in these
and from you my viewers who introduced
me to a lot of great authors who I
ordinarily wouldn't have you know spent
the time to read the last thing I'll say
is this this worlds of speculative
fiction series is actually my guilty
pleasure reading it's an excuse for me
to read speculative fiction that
otherwise I might not budget the time in
my busy schedule to do so again give me
your comments and I'm really happy to
see whatever people want me to do will
will come up with it and and see what
fits into this schedule well and what
makes sense